The heroes of Avengers: Infinity War aren't
set to converge on the silver screen until
April 27th.
However, as part of the movie's marketing
run, Marvel Studios will be showing the first
30 minutes of Avengers: Infinity War to critics,
fans, and general press over the next couple
of weeks.
One such screening took place in London on
Thursday, April 5th, and it gave the world
the first reaction to the film.
Digital Spy Film staff were lucky enough to
catch the half hour of footage, posting their
thoughts about it on Twitter:
"We've just seen 30 minutes of Avengers: Infinity
War.
Can't say too much but it's way ambitious,
it'll switch tones between different groups
(the Guardians sequence had a very different,
look, feel, and soundtrack to the New York
scenes), and it's going to be funny.
Still no Hawkeye!"
It's obvious from the film's eye-popping trailers
and the various television spots that have
aired that the film's cast will, indeed, be
sliced and diced into groups.
There's the Battle of New York squad that
consists of Iron Man, Hulk, Doctor Strange,
and Wong, plus Peter Parker, who teams up
with them later in his Iron Spider suit.
Captain America collaborates with his Nomads
group that includes Falcon, Bucky Barnes,
Black Widow, Black Panther, and Okoye — with
the potential for Vision and Scarlet Witch
to meet up with the team later as well.
Then we've got Thor meeting the Guardians
of the Galaxy, of course.
"Who the hell are you guys?"
The mention of tonal shifts in this evaluation
of Avengers: Infinity War also lines up with
something composer Alan Silvestri once said.
The movie will feature quick turns in style,
with the music changing to match each mood.
Just a few days before the first film reaction
surfaced, Silvestri told The Hollywood Reporter:
"I wrapped Infinity War yesterday, and it
was a really different experience than anything
I'd done before, especially in regard to the
approach and balancing quick shifts in tone."
It also appears that screenwriters Christopher
Markus and Stephen McFeely took some of the
humor that made Captain America: Civil War
such a standout entry in the MCU and infused
it into the Avengers: Infinity War story.
"Doctor Strange…" "Oh, we're using our made
up names? Then I'm Spider-Man."
The only downside to this whole thing?
Jeremy Renner's Hawkeye is still missing,
even 30 minutes into Avengers: Infinity War.
Maybe he'll make an epic entrance in the second
or third act?
We can only wait to find out.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!
"Also here's a theory, maybe he's not shown, because in actuality, he is Thanos! Dun dun DUNNNNN!!!"